Hello everyone. This is Jyn from Next
Level Commander and today we are here to
talk about why your budget commander
decks will be stronger than the $20,000
decks with all the blings and black
border duels and staples. And no, we're
not talking about politics and threat
assessment today, although that is
definitely a part of the equation. The
idea for this video stemmed from a
conversation I had with my friend Jimmy.
Jimmy was excited about the new Final
Fantasy spoilers, but not the prices.
But lately, this product is not for me.
Vibes has been strong with Jimmy and
also my entire group, which consists of
a lot of folks who are either in school
or still paying for it. Now, when I
shared with him the spoiler of Vivie,
his favorite Final Fantasy character,
Jimmy was excited for a moment, but then
he remarked, "Ah, is it spells? It's
expensive, isn't it?" Yes, it can be.
You open up the EDH wreck page and it
gives you the storm build with expensive
enablers like Jessica's will and
interaction like Fierce Guardianship. As
Magic players, it's natural for us to
associate price with power level. And we
strive to get these quote unquote most
powerful cards for our decks, thus
further increasing the prices and
solidifying their stable status. I mean,
thousands of people are playing it. It
must be good. All right. Now, this echo
chamber, feedback loop, whatever you
want to call it, does greatly reduce the
need for exploration and contemplation
in our format, for better or for worse.
Now, I'm not saying that these staple
cards are not good. No, no. I mean,
these staples will perform well whether
your commander is Vive, Misix, or Sliver
Overlord. But just because they are the
most generically powerful choices across
the format, doesn't mean they are
actually the best card for your
commander. Not always. Let's take a look
at BB. The abilities immediately scream
storm. The counter and the ping ability
triggers this heristic in magic players
and your mind immediately jumps to this
face. Or maybe this monkey. But being
financially responsible like Jimmy, he
has to explore other options. After a
closer look, it's not hard to see that
the ability we should be building around
is actually the first one. Mana equals
power. Titan strength nets you four
mana, three from the spell, one from the
plus one counter. Brute force is another
four. Monstrous rage gives you four more
and you get to do some role playing. Now
throw an unleash fury in there and the
sky is the limit. Heck, if you can't
find enough palm spells in red, we can
also sprinkle in some blue ones like
behind the mask. One mana plus 5 plus 4
or fleeting reflection for potentially a
lot of power. But don't play too many of
the blue ones because they don't stack
well with each other. And now you find
yourself sitting with 10 blue mana on
turn four. H, what do we do with that?
pull from tomorrow. Blue Sun, Zenith,
Mindprint. Okay, it is still turn four
and now we have 10 cards in hand and a
12 power commander. So, how do we win?
Oh, yeah. We can just attack and throw
in some protection spells and counter
spells mostly to keep Vivv around and we
have the deck. Vivv Voltron costs a
little more than a precon, but the
process of building it, actually
thinking through what makes Vivv unique
led to a more synergistic and satisfying
deck. Being on a budget really forces us
to think deeper about a commander and
card selection. Meanwhile, I find a lot
of players with slightly bigger budgets,
myself included, to simply toss in the
most popular card choices and be
satisfied with them because I mean
they're good cards and they will feel
good to play. But are they really the
best cards? Rather than playing cards
that are, say, 70% synergistic with
every commander, Jimmy has to look for
cards that are 100% synergistic with his
commander. Now, I'm not saying that
players who pay don't think, but often
times they are not forced to go a little
further beneath the surface level. And
you hear this from older players. They
talk about how nowadays commanders
becoming more and more like wizards
build the deck for you and you just have
to collect the cards. And there is some
truth to that. The synergies are so
obvious and on the nose that there's
still room for creativity, but very
little need. Whether it's budget or
something else, restriction breeds
creativity and growth. Now, Vivv is a
fairly simple example, and I'm not
saying that this is definitely more
powerful than the storm build. It
probably isn't. But here we are talking
about the long run, the thinking,
digging, and testing more unique
strategies will give you a much deeper
understanding of the format and its
dynamics. What cards work and more
importantly, why do they work? Let's
take a look at another example, which is
my friend Jack's Derevy deck. Now, if
you open EDH of Derevy, immediately you
see the likes of Voice of Victory, Birds
of Paradise, Balloon Tender, Esper
Sentinel, you're at close to $100 before
you even cast Derevy. And these are not
bad cards by any means, but looking at
Derevy, it's a really powerful card. And
these commanders tend to reward playing
bad cards with 100% synergy more than
good cards with 70% synergy.
Jackstack had raised the alarm sapper in
migration cloning around join the dense
heck even the early days he had a
fencing ace just to get the double untap
trigger with these extremely low to the
ground token makers he's able to throw
in cheap enchantments like fertile
ground and wild growth and generate a
lot of mana but only during combat he
used that mana to cast instant speed
draw spells like thirst for knowledge
and jay's ingenuity or even a large pole
from tomorrow this mana and card
advantage snowballs into more tokens and
more mana which quickly overwhelms
everyone with pawn spells like
vitalizing wind or a welltimed mirror
weave. Seriously, the snowballing is
insane. I've seen him alchemist refuge
into approach of the second sun into
draw seven and approach again all during
combat on turn six. Now this works
because rather than playing cards that
have obvious on the surface synergies
with Derevy, he's created something more
top down and holistic. Rather than
individual cards, he came up with a game
plan with cards all contributing to that
plan. The entire deck costed around $40
and this DVI I can say with confidence
will destroy most EDH wreck direct lists
that are 10 times the price. To sum
things up, I genuinely believe that
commander is not paid to win. The better
players and deck builders will always
come out ahead. Commander is a format
with nearly 30,000 legal cards. If we
look past the fear of missing out on the
best stables, we unlock what made this
format so magical in the first place,
creativity, exploration, and expression.
So, thank you for watching. This is Next
Level Commander, and I hope that through
this channel, we can level up together
to be better players and deck builders.
So, please
subscribe or send me your channel. I'll
subscribe to
you. Whatever works. I just want someone
to talk
to. All right. See you in the next
video.